this video is brought to you by opera
[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here let me ask you
something if you had the chance to wipe
out the worst thing that ever happened
to you to make it so that you had no
memory of the event at all would you do
it or more importantly should you these
are the questions at the heart of
today's movie Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind first released in 2004
this lasting film opened to rave reviews
charmed by innovative cinematography
unusual structure and an all-star cast
critics and audiences alike fell in love
with this quirky haunting story about
the nature of human relationships and
heartbreak but after 16 years does the
movie hold up was Kate Winslet just
lucky enough to cash in on the Manic
Pixie dream girl phenomenon before it
got stale or is there something really
profound about the relationship she and
Jim Carrey portray on the screen to
answer this question we have to get to
know the uncredited star of this movie
the human brain specifically we're going
to look to neuroscience to examine what
this film says about the way the brain
works and what that means for us as
human beings living with those brains
sound complicated damage smoothies this
isn't rocket science it's brain surgery
don't worry we'll break it down for you
in this wise crack position on Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind deep or
dumb and spoilers ahead for one of the
few movies ever to put Frodo Baggins in
the Hulk in the same room but before we
get into it I want to give a shout-out
to this week's sponsor opera we're all
online a lot these days so why not have
the best browsing experience possible
opera is the all-in-one browser that
gives you features to connect to your
favorite platforms and make your time
online more productive for starters you
can design the way you want your browser
to look and organize all your tabs
there's also a workspace a feature that
allows you to create and customize the
way your tabs are saved for optimal
workflow opera also features integrated
messengers so you can access facebook
Messenger whatsapp and telegram all on
the side so you don't have to check
every app individually while browsing
you can watch videos from Netflix
YouTube or almost any other video
provider with the browser's video
pop-out tool they even offer a built-in
VPN and
blocker which saves you the headache of
downloading extensions and keeping track
of subscriptions opera includes all this
and more which you can check out for
yourself by downloading the browser
today you can download opera for free by
clicking the link in the description
once you've downloaded it let us know
what your favorite feature is if you're
watching on mobile you can still click
the link in the description to download
later so make sure you use our link and
now back to the show
alright guys let's do a quick recap
sad-sack Joel barish wakes up one day to
find a huge scratch on his car and most
of his journal entries missing on a whim
he ditches his usual commute and hops on
a train to Montauk where he meets and
starts to fall in love with the quirky
and impulsive clementine kruczynski
after some jumping back and forth on the
timeline we discovered that Joel and
Clementine have actually met before in
fact they've had a whole life together
dating for what appears to have been
several years neither lover recognizes
the other because they independently
arrange to have their memories of the
painful relationship erased by a company
called lacunae Inc the film cuts between
Joel's bedroom where lacunae technicians
are working to wipe memories of
Clementine from his brain and the inside
of his head as he changes his mind about
the procedure and fights to keep those
memories safe while Joel and clementines
do ultimately lose their memories of
each other they manage to retain a vague
impression of their feelings which sends
them to Montauk at the same time at the
end of the film its heavily implied that
the whole cycle of their relationship
will begin again to discern whether the
film is deep or not we need to dive into
some philosophical and ethical questions
about the proper use of technology and
our innate human abilities when it comes
to building our identities selves and
experiences at a very basic level the
movie's plot is driven by Joel's choices
about what to do with his brain that is
whether or not to eliminate Clementine
from his consciousness he starts off
wanting to alter his brain even to the
point of harming it in order to avoid
the pain of having loved and lost
clementines is there any risk of brain
damage well technically speaking the
procedure is
heavy drinking nothingness but as he
goes through the night and starts to
realize what losing Clementine really
means the eradication of a huge part of
his life an emotional experience he
makes a choice to fight the procedure
and preserve as much of her as he can
pain and all Joel's decisions boil down
to a choice between comfort and growth
he can live a diminished but easy life
without Clementine or opt for a harder
but richer experience with her in it but
this is also a choice between two ways
of approaching his physical brain either
as something to be trimmed down and
controlled for the sake of efficiency or
something to be used for its full messy
potential whatever the consequences of
that growth and freedom might be
philosopher Catherine Malibu has written
about this exact dilemma in her
conveniently titled book what should we
do with our brain the book draws on
neuro scientific research to discuss the
concept of the brain's plasticity when
we say plasticity many of us are
actually thinking about the far more
limited and nefarious concept of
flexibility plasticity involves
adaptation and according to Malibu is an
agency of disobedience to every
constituted form a refusal to submit to
a model to be flexible is to receive a
form or impression to be docile to not
explode put it another way research and
experience show that our brains are able
to both adapt to circumstances and
resist them to work with change and to
create it Sbarro Malibu's analogy
ourselves are like plastic explosives
being able to mold to a given shape if
necessary but also capable of radically
changing our own form and that of our
environment flexibility on the other
hand involves always taking the path of
least resistance looked at from this
point of view Joel's decision to erase
or keep his memories of Clementine can
be seen as a choice between exercising
be full plasticity of his brain or doing
the flexible thing by destroying those
parts of his brain that are making going
in both Malibu's book and eternal
sunshine flexibility is presented as the
guiding philosophy of neoliberal
capitalism according to both hex we live
in an economic system that demands
flexibility from its actors and offers
them products and services which will
increase their flexibility for a price
eternal sunshine perhaps it's
simplistically portrays business as the
process of taking advantage of people
who are suffering from confusion or pain
Joel's very first lines frame
Valentine's Day as a corporate plot to
sabotage our emotional state today is a
holiday invented by a greeting card
companies like creme but the film
ultimately earns that critique keeping
with the same theme the movie makes it
clear that lacunae Inc survives by
profiting off of people's desire to rid
those crappy feelings of heartache as
Mary points out it's even implied that
clients may become dependent on the
memory erasing procedure over time and
will go to extreme lengths to get it
done the ways in which the company takes
advantage of compromised people become
less subtle and more disturbing as the
film progresses shortly after arriving
at Joel's apartment the lacunae Inc
technicians assigned to wipe his
memories turn his home into their own
personal Airbnb drinking getting high
and even having sex near his unconscious
body this trend takes a turn for the
seriously [ __ ] up when we learned that
one of the technicians stole a pair of
clementines underwear while they were
erasing her memory I mean they were
clean and all and that he's been using
information stolen from Joel's letters
to try and trick her into falling in
love with him the unethical behavior
reaches its climax when we find out that
Howard coerced Mary his own secretary to
wipe her memory after the two of them
had an affair together what Joel
Clementine and Laguna's other customers
lack that leaves them open to such
exploitation is the flexibility that
society demands of them such a demand
according to Malibu is at odds with our
true nature as human beings as beings
with plastic brains we can indeed bend
when we wish but we're also capable of
resistance creation and other acts of
free will in the face of obstacles too
often though in a culture so tightly
focused on work and
activity the full plasticity of our
brains is reduced to the concept of
flexibility and presented simply as the
possibility of increasing or decreasing
performance very often the brain is
analyzed as personal capital this idea
of the brain as personal capital
something you can optimize and invest in
for greater output like a factory
production line is even more prevalent
today than when Malibu first wrote about
it in 2008 in Silicon Valley and Beyond
we find workers taking drastic steps to
alter their brain functioning for
improved performance on the job workers
engage in so-called brain hacking
practices fine-tuned sleep and break
schedules the use of nootropics and even
LSD micro dosing in an attempt to put in
longer hours and produce more work
whether or not this served their own
health well-being or growth these
practices and others are examples of
Malibu's flexibility in action hijacking
your own brain chemistry to meets an
unreasonable deadline demonstrates a
profound ability and willingness to
adapt to circumstances rather than
improve them from an economic
perspective than to be flexible is to
upskill reorient and change as often as
necessary to satisfy the demands of
society rather than take the drastic
action of trying to change those demands
the Kuna Inc promises its customers the
flexibility that is so highly prized in
our society and economy without their
procedures done dr. Howard's patients
are inflexible fixated on past lovers
dead pets or any of the countless
disappointments and setbacks that are
part of being human
he explains his service to Joel as a way
for people to become unstuck not by
overcoming the challenges they face miss
kruczynski was not happy and she
we provide that possibility but by
smoothing out their lives so they can
continue forward uninterrupted when you
awake in the morning
you'll find yourself in your own bed as
if nothing happened in her discussion of
mood regulating drugs like prozac Malibu
claims that our society commonly judges
such treatments based on their ability
to reduce vulnerability chronic
disturbance and psychical precariousness
and give back the appetite for mobility
the capacity to rid oneself of rigidity
and a fixity in one's identity in other
words we say that a psychiatric drug or
treatment is working when it makes the
person using it more flexible in their
approach to work relationships etc now
this is not to say that Malibu is
against such medication on the contrary
she makes a point of saying how useful
it can be she's simply pointing out that
the discourse around the effectiveness
of psychiatric medication tends to focus
on whether it makes the person more
pliable productive and eager to fit in
rather than on whether it helps them be
more strong-willed creative etc Howard's
procedure can be thought of as just such
a flexibility enhancing mood stabiliser
in some sense he is a modern-day
lobotomist cutting out those parts of
the brain which are thought to be the
source of uncomfortable unproductive
feelings like sadness depression or
anxiety when the wider system demands
its individual members adapt no measure
is too extreme what unites Howard's
patients or his target demographic is a
desire to shortcut the hard work of
integrating negative experiences into
their lives so they can go back to
living in a way that doesn't require
change they want to express flexibility
rather than plasticity and Howard is
willing to help them do it
Clementine poignant ly expresses this
understandable wish to wipe away
difficulties while describing her
childhood to Joel my favorite is this
ugly girls doll who I call Clementine
and I keep yelling at her you can't be
ugly
be pretty
it's weird like if I can transform her I
would magically change too if as Malibu
claims trying to magically change
ourselves by being eternally
accommodating is a waste of our true
potential then what should we do instead
what would a fully realize plastic brain
and self actually be like in other words
if we choose not to automatically go
along with the demands to be flexible
then what is the alternative we're
fighting for according to her the
plasticity of the self implies balance
between the preservation of constancy
and the exposure of this constancy to
accidents to the outside to other nests
in general she adds that if we didn't
explode at each transition if we didn't
destroy ourselves a bit we could not
live simplify Malibu claims that to be
really human to express plasticity is to
balance the need to adapt against the
need for growth and change yes we all
decide to make sacrifices for the sake
of productivity from time to time we
might stay late at the office for one
night because the boss asked us to or
skip out on movie night with friends
because our teacher wants that term
paper submitted by midnight but when we
become so flexible that we iron out
every inefficiency in our lives when
we're so afraid of explosions that we
take no risks then we're in trouble in
other words the spotless mind from the
Alexander Pope poem that gives the movie
its name isn't a desirable thing at all
we need our spots traumas heartaches etc
in order to live full lives that have
some meaning outside of our ability to
satisfy demand how happy is the
blameless Vestals lot the world
forgetting by the world for God
eternal sunshine of a spotless mind each
prayer accepted so what do we do as
individuals in a society that demand we
stamp out the Troublesome unproductive
parts of our brains in order to succeed
how should we make the best use of our
brains that is how do we accomplish the
most cyberpunk of goals that Malibu sets
up in her books opening pages neuronal
liberation her answer is simple we ought
to refuse to be flexible and exercise
the explosive creative dimensions of our
brains plasticity to the fullest extent
possible as she puts it we should
visualize the possibility of saying no
to an afflicting economic political and
media attic culture that celebrates only
the triumph of flexibility blessing
obedient individuals who have no greater
merit than that of knowing how to bow
their heads and smile Joel Clementine
and Mary take up this fight by pushing
back against the erasure of their own
and others memories that is by being
difficult and refusing to let things run
smoothly for the sake of smoothness Joel
demonstrates plasticity by working with
his projected image of Clementine to
evade Howard and his technicians
somewhere where I don't belong and we
hide there till morning and when it
becomes clear that he won't be able to
run forever
Joel even manages to seed a subconscious
direction for his waking post-procedure
self again via his image of Clementine
while Joel wakes up and follows his
subliminal urgings back to Clementine
Mary raged the lacunae Inc offices and
sends out all of their files to their
previous customers in effect ruining the
procedure for all of them and upsetting
the smooth operation of the company my
name is Mary Smith we've met but you
don't want that we don't we're current
come hired tired to have part of your
memory erased with their painful history
thus revealed to them present-day Joel
and Clementine must decide whether or
not to pursue a relationship together
knowing in advance that they are likely
to hurt each other very badly their
choice is the film's ultimate example of
plasticity in action
things I'll get bored with you and feel
trapped because that's what happens with
me the flexible thing for Joel and
Clementine to do in this situation would
be to accept the futility of pursuing a
relationship together and go their
separate ways to live comfortable
productive lives either alone or with
better suited partners instead they
willingly blow up their chances at
untroubled singledom or functional
romance opting instead for a dynamic
which has been empirically proven to not
work inherent in our plasticity is the
ability to make choices of our own free
will perhaps especially when those
choices don't make much sense the film's
final shot is a looping clip of Joel and
Clementine playing on a snow-covered
beach in Montauk implying that this
cycle is likely to play itself out again
their relationship isn't perfect it may
not even be a good idea but it is their
choice made in defiance of flexibility
and therefore an expression of the
brain's plasticity that is its vast
potential to create and destroy both
itself and its environment these neuro
rebels have done Malibu proud and
they've earned themselves a solid deep
from us but what do you think wisecrack
are their ethical or practical limits to
how much we can and should optimize our
brains for given purposes have a
favorite movie or TV show that explores
how people relate to their own minds let
us know your thoughts in the comments
below a big thanks to our amazing
patrons for supporting our Channel and
the podcasts hit the subscribe button
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]